tesla may have six factories around the
world but none is more important than
its mega factory near austin texas this
building is the the most advanced car
factory that earth has ever seen
if you could put the building on its
side tesla's new headquarters would be
taller than the world's tallest
skyscrapers including dubai's burj
khalifa according to our calculations
you could fit 194 billion hamsters in
this building
billions of hamsters and one day
millions of cars are expected to roll
off the assembly line for the past 20
years tesla has been following its
carefully concocted plan to electrify
the world
in 2006 elon musk released tesla's
master plan part 1 on its website it
consisted of first building a sports car
the roadster it was really expensive
with a starting price of over a hundred
thousand second using that money to
build an affordable car the model s and
x though both are pricey and still out
of the reach of most third use that
money to build an even more affordable
car which gave us the model 3 in the
model y crossover finally while doing
above also provides zero emission
electric power generation options in
reference to tesla's solar lineup of
solar panels roof tiles and power walls
to supply energy to your home a decade
later tesla came out with master plan
part de or part two create stunning
solar roofs with seamlessly integrated
battery storage tesla solar tiles have
been more difficult to install than
originally thought because no two roofs
are the same i wanted to detail in
another video that i'll link in my
description
second expand the electric vehicle
product line to address all major
segments besides the s 3 x and y tesla's
cyber truck is finally slated to go into
production next year according to musk
after a long wait the semi is also in
progress third develop a self-driving
capability that is 10 times safer than
manual via massive fleet learning the
software to make the tesla fully
self-driving is still being developed
which is connected to the final point of
master plan part two
enable your car to make money for you
when you aren't using it a self-driving
network of cars or robo taxis is
dependent on fsd being complete in march
musk confirmed he's working on master
plan part 3 despite part 2 not being
fully finished however he's always been
one to look ahead part 3 is likely to
see electric cars streaming off assembly
lines at a rate never before seen scale
that no company has uh ever achieved in
in the history of humanity tesla's
growth has already been astounding it's
the fastest growing car manufacturer in
the world currently delivering a million
cars a year but if you know anything
about elon musk his appetite is bigger
if tesla's share of the total vehicle
output market globally is about one
percent musk says his company is aiming
for 20 of the pie in other words he
wants one out of every five new cars on
the road to be one of his he's
repeatedly said developing prototypes
are a piece of cake compared to the
complicated process of scaling up
production the only way to achieve that
scale is to make your factory as
efficient as possible the layout of
gigatexas is very different compared to
tesla's original headquarters in fremont
california fremont consisted of separate
buildings making different parts for
example the seats were made in a totally
different building from the main
assembly line so it wasn't as efficient
as it could have been
whereas now with gigatexas everything is
under one roof almost like an integrated
circuit raw materials come in one door
and the finished product goes at the
other within the factory tesla is also
simplifying the way it makes cars thanks
to its giant casting machines known as
the giga press the austin made model ys
are produced with only two body pieces
at the front and rear the ys also
contain 1 600 fewer welds fewer steps on
the production line translate to lower
cost speaking of lowering costs tesla is
building its own battery cells in-house
the 4680s these next generation
batteries pack more energy the company
says they'll have 16
more range they're totally different
from the batteries of the past in the
same way that aircraft wings store fuel
instead of needing a fuel tank tesla
decided to build a battery that doesn't
contain excess structure
so what's next for tesla it could truly
transform into an ai company musk has
always insisted the goal of tesla is not
to be a car company but a technology
company that's developing software so
the cars can drive themselves although
we thought robo-taxis were going to look
like regular teslas musk now says
they'll have a futuristic look he said
on tesla's first quarter earnings call
that the robo taxi won't have a steering
wheel or pedals and the company is
targeting 2024 for production if the
cyber truck is anything to go by then
the robo taxi will likely turn heads as
well
all of the tech in the teslas is
expected to be packed into their robots
according to tesla the optimus comes
complete with autopilot cameras in the
head and a full self-driving computer in
the body the bot is designed to take
care of boring repetitive tasks that
humans normally do like running to the
grocery store when musk revealed the
tesla bot at the company's ai day in
2021 some thought it was a joke it
didn't help that the bot was actually a
human dressed as a robot since there's
not yet a prototype but according to
musk this is no laughing matter i was
surprised that people did not realize
the magnitude of the optimus robot
program those who are insightful or
looking to listen carefully will
understand
that optimus ultimately will be worth
more than the car business
worth more than fsd
the labor market is reported to be 16
times greater than the car market if
tesla produces a robot that can do what
humans do this could reshape what we do
with our time beyond our imagination the
tesla started out 20 years ago as a
company trying to build an electric car
now it's trying to develop cars that
will one day drive themselves and if it
accomplishes that it will transform into
an ai company with an army of robo-taxis
and robots and a full clean energy suite
that is all tied together in one neat
package
here at newsthink i'm involved in every
aspect of the storytelling process from
research to script writing to video
editing i try to be as productive as
possible and it really helps to be
healthy ever since i began taking by
optimizers at the start of the year i
found that i functioned a lot better my
doctor suggested i take probiotics to
improve digestive health so that's what
i've been doing i've been taking their
probiotics with my lunch every single
day and also for dinner i've been taking
their magnesium breakthrough which i've
noticed has significantly helped improve
my sleep now that i've been taking
magnesium breakthrough i found that i
can actually sleep through the entire
night without waking up most magnesium
supplements fail because they're
synthetic or use preservatives when you
get all seven critical forms of
magnesium your body gets a serious
upgrade so you can feel better
throughout your day to find out more
head to magnesium breakthrough dot com
slash newsthink to get a 10 discount my
custom link is my description and pin
comment and don't forget to use my promo
code newsthink10 at checkout thanks for
watching for newsthink i'm cindy palm